- Have you ever gotten a
notice that looks like this?
It looks like a scam, right?
It looks like it can't possibly be true.
But this is a notice of a
class action settlement.
And there's actually a very good chance
that this is on the level.
And it's possible that you stand
to make some money off of it,
or at least get something of value.
But you'd be forgiven if you thought
that this was complete
nonsense, because I mean,
just look at it.
Look, lawyers are good
at writing things down.
They are not great at graphic design.
But the biggest question
is, what do you do
when you get a notice like this?
How do you know if it's real?
Well, as it happens,
your favorite bird lawyer
has actually litigated and settled
countless numbers of
class action settlements
worth hundreds of millions of dollars.
So let's talk about the good, the bad,
and the extremely ugly
about class action lawsuits.
And most importantly, what you should do
if you get a notice of
class action settlement.
So join me as I spill some legal tea.
Sponsored by Trade Coffee.
So this is no joke, I really
did receive this notice
of class action settlement
related to an Epic Games lawsuit.
Apparently, at some point
I played either Fortnite
or Rocket League, and I might
be entitled to some money
or some benefits as a
result of this settlement.
It makes sense, because I
will never get that time
that I spent on Fortnight back.
So I would really, really like
to be compensated for that.
And the things that we're
gonna talk about today
will relate to this particular
class action lawsuit,
but it should apply to just
about any class action notice
that you receive.
So let's first talk about
what is a class action suit,
because this is one of the
most misunderstood things
in all of law.
Generally, when you have a lawsuit,
you personally sue somebody
else, because the dollar amounts
in question are worth
getting compensation for
what you think you were wronged over.
But a class action is
the opposite of that.
It's where a lot of people
were probably harmed
in very, very small ways that
it would never make sense
for them to individually file suit.
But instead, if you wrap
all of them together,
the class of people, all of those people
who are in the same situation,
can get compensation
from the company or another individual.
And when you group them all together,
it makes it worthwhile to file suit.
Part of it is a punitive reason.
We don't want companies
to engage in misbehavior
that they'd never
otherwise be punished for
because simply the
individuals would never think
to hire their own personal attorney.
So every state and the
federal system has laws
on the books to allow people
to file a class action.
And a class action gets this reputation
that's sort of like Rico.
If you file a class action,
then it's a super, super serious lawsuit.
And a class action can deal
with large dollar amounts,
especially because you're aggregating
a whole bunch of claims.
But just because it's a
class action doesn't mean
that it's necessarily a super
scary or super nasty lawsuit.
Sometimes class actions settle
for hundreds of millions of dollars,
sometimes they go to trial,
and sometimes they're simply dismissed
and no one gets anything.
But the most important thing to remember
about a class action is
that it requires a class,
a group of people who
suffered a similar injury,
that all of their injuries
and all of the things
that happened to them
are very, very similar.
Because a court is not going
to engage in a class action
if it has to individually
look at every single person.
If the calculation that
goes into the damages
for each individual person is different,
it's probably not likely to
give rise to a class action.
The class has to be very similar.
The damages that they suffered
have to be very similar.
And it has to be easy for
the court to ascertain all
of these things together
there, because they're dealing
with potentially hundreds, thousands,
and sometimes even millions of people.
So imagine, if you will, a person runs
into a crowd and just
starts punching people.
Now, it could be that
that person has punched
a hundred people in that
crowd, and you might think
that could give rise to a
class action, but probably not,
because maybe one person
was punched in the stomach,
one person was punched in the face,
one person suffered a broken bone,
and one person was barely damaged at all.
Because all of those injuries
are so fact specific,
that's not the kind of
thing that gives rise
to a class action.
But on the other hand,
let's look at something
that could be easily
adjudicated as a class action.
Let's imagine that there's
a big cell phone provider,
and let's say that they
improperly put a $1 fee
on your bill that shouldn't be there.
And let's say they bill that
out to a million customers.
Well, it's really easy to
ascertain those people.
You just look at the spreadsheet of
what people were charged what fees,
and the damages are all the same.
It's just that one extra
fee that shouldn't be there.
That's exactly the kinds of fact situation
that's likely to give rise to a valuable
and valid class action lawsuit.
So now let's turn to this Fortnite
and Rocket League lawsuit
and use that as an example of
what happens when a
class action has filed.
And here, because this court
case has already gotten
to the settlement stage,
all the documents are
helpfully displayed right on
the court settlement website.
And yes, this website is legitimate.
It's not meant to look good,
it's just meant to be legally sufficient.
So what the plaintiffs
originally alleged is
that the makers of Fortnite
and Rocket League engaged
in some unfair business practices.
And in particular, if you
dig into the complaint,
what you'll see is that
the plaintiff alleged
that a lot of minors
entered into transactions
on these video games and
weren't allowed to back out
of these transactions
because they were minors.
And it also alleges some other
unfair business practices,
as well as some claims
related to random loot crates
and people spending a
thousand virtual dollars
on loot crate related things.
We'll never know if that
was in fact true or not,
because one of the
benefits of settlement is
that you don't have to go
through the expense of discovery
and the whole trial to get to the truth
of the matter asserted,
you can just settle
and say that you're not admitting anything
or you're not admitting fault,
if you're the defendant.
And here the parties
engaged in litigation,
but eventually came to
the conclusion that it was
in everyone's best interest
to settle the claims
instead of spending
money on the litigation.
Now, when you come to that conclusion,
it's not as easy as just
signing on the dotted line.
In fact, both the plaintiffs
and the defendants
have to go to the court to get the court
to sign off on the settlement itself.
It has to be court approved.
The court has to make sure
that the class of people
are actually being fairly compensated
and that everything else is on the level.
Now, in addition to that,
you have to determine
certain things, like what is the class.
And here, based on the
notice, it says that
"You're a member of the settlement class
if at any time between July 1, 2015
and February 25, 2021, you got a Fortnite
or Rocket League account that
you used to play either game
on any device in any mod
and A, exchanged in-game
virtual currency for any in-game benefit
or B, made a purchase of virtual currency
or other in-game benefit for use
within Fortnite or Rocket League."
So if you fit that description,
you're entitled to some
relief from the court.
And if you look at the
settlement agreement,
the lawyers estimate that
there were approximately
12 million people who have accounts
who played the games
and fit that description
across both Fortnite and Rocket League.
And now we get to the part
that everyone is waiting for.
What could you possibly
get out of this settlement?
Well, here, the defendants
have agreed to spend
up to $26.5 million, but
that's unfortunately not
what the class is going to get.
And here's where things
get a little bit ugly,
and where I'm afraid we're going to have
to spill a little bit of legal tea.
Because the thing is,
the plaintiffs' lawyers
are not only negotiating on
behalf of the class of people
who were injured, but
they're also negotiating
on behalf of themselves,
because they're going to
get a cut of this payout.
Sometimes that payout might
be 10% of the class payout.
Sometimes it might be 50
or 60% of the class payout.
But the good news is that
the court is supervising
all of this, and they're
trying to make sure
that the lawyers aren't
taking too, too much
from the class settlement.
Look, the lawyers have to get paid.
If it weren't for them, these
suits would never be filed.
But there's a fine line between
being compensated fairly
for your time and also just
getting a huge windfall.
But in addition to the
plaintiffs' lawyers,
there's also the class representative.
To be able to file a class action,
you have to have an
individual who represents
the rest of the class fairly.
And that person or individuals
also need to be compensated.
Generally, they're not paid all that much,
maybe five to $10,000 at most.
And sure, that's a lot of money,
but your average class
representative is gonna
put in a lot of work.
They're probably gonna need to be deposed.
They'll have to talk to the lawyers.
And I wouldn't wish that on anyone.
So in the grand scheme
of things, the payout
for the class representative
is usually not a huge amount
as represented by the total payout.
So how much will the class actually get?
Well, that depends on how many people
actually take up the settlement,
because it's a bit of a moving target.
The more people that sign
up for the class action,
the less each individual gets.
And believe me, the fact
that I'm making a video
about this is going to give the lawyers
who are in charge of the
settlement, both on the defense
and the plaintiff side,
a complete heart attack,
because now I've publicized this suit,
and the uptick on the number
of people who are going to ask
for a class payment is probably
gonna go through the roof.
So, sorry, guys.
So what will any
individual class member get
as a result if they participate
in this class action?
Well, you have to look at
the settlement agreement,
but they might be able
to get a maximum of $50.
Depends on what kind of
damages you suffered.
Or you have the option to receive payments
in virtual dollars, V-Bucks on Fortnite
or Rocket League, up
to a maximum of 13,500,
which they estimate to be
worth about a hundred dollars
if you had to purchase them in-game.
Now, of course, the
virtual dollars are not
actually worth a hundred dollars
to the game manufacturers,
despite the fact that that's
how much it might cost you
if you wanted to buy them.
So they would much rather you
take your settlement payment
in the form of the virtual dollars
instead of an actual cash payment.
So people who are members
of this punitive class
have a couple of options.
They can go to this
website, they can sign up,
and they can say that they actively want
the additional benefit of either the cash
or the virtual dollars
as part of a payment
for this class action lawsuit.
People, of course, can do nothing as well.
That's what most people do.
They look at these
emails and these notices
and they think that
this is a complete scam.
They don't want to provide
their personal information,
and they just simply do nothing.
And this particular
settlement provides that
if they don't do anything,
they will at least get a
thousand virtual dollars.
Theoretically, also you could write
into the settlement
administrator and you could say
that you don't want to participate
in this settlement agreement
and you can exclude
yourself from the class.
The main benefit there
is that regardless of
what happens in the class,
you might be able to file suit
on your own behalf, but
you'd never want to do that
because the dollar amounts
are way, way too small.
And additionally, you can
also attend the hearing
on this settlement agreement.
Because right now we're in the
preliminary approval stage.
The court has looked at this settlement.
Both the plaintiffs and the
defendants are advocating
that the court should
approve this settlement,
but they need more information.
They need to know how
many people are going
to sign up for the class.
They need to know how many people object,
how many people don't want
to be included in this class.
Because if there are too many people
who reject the settlement,
then the court might have
to tell the parties to go
back to the drawing board.
And here's one of the craziest things.
Sometimes if too many people
sign up for the benefits
of the settlement agreement,
it kind of blows up the whole deal.
We saw this in the Equifax class action,
where they offered up to $150 per person
whose privacy rights were violated
when Equifax completely screwed the pooch
in terms of user privacy.
And then so many people
signed up to get the $150,
it broke the bank and the parties had
to go back to the drawing board again.
And theoretically, since
I'm publicizing this video,
that might happen here, too.
Yeah, sorry about that.
But effectively this is the same process
that everyone goes through
in class action settlements.
It starts with notifying
the potential class,
usually through email, but maybe it's
through the telephone,
using these jenky notices
that look like a scam.
Then you have to go to these websites
that look like they came
out of Geocities in 1994.
And you then have to provide
your personal information
to sign up for the class on the hopes
that you'll get some sort of payout
from the settlement agreement.
And of course, then you have to wait
for the court to approve
the final settlement.
And then maybe a year or two later,
you might actually get a check in the mail
or some virtual dollars
deposited into your bank account.
It takes a very, very long time.
And while we spilled the
tea about class actions,
I'd never spill my cup of coffee
because I get my coffee from Trade.
After all, a lawyer is only as good
as their last cup of coffee.
Trade is great not only because
they have a huge selection
of your favorite coffees,
but they also have
a fantastic quiz to get you matched up
with coffee recommendations based
on your personal preferences.
I have a very specific taste in coffee.
Basically, I want something
that tastes like hot chocolate
and pairs well with milk, lots
and lots of milk and sugar.
And Trade was able to
find me a perfect roast.
And now since the weather is getting warm,
they have a huge selection
of cold brews as well.
With Trade, you can discover new coffees
from the nation's top roasters.
Trade matches you to your own
personal selection of coffee
and conveniently delivers
it directly to you.
And if you know what you like,
they probably already
have your favorite roaster
in stock at a fantastic price.
So if you'd like to try Trade Coffee,
Legal Eagles will get 50%
off of their first bag
when they sign up and get free shipping.
Just click on the link in the description,
take the quiz, and choose your frequency,
whether you want one
bag or a subscription,
and then rate your coffee
so your suggestions get even better.
You can even choose whole
beans or your preferred grind.
It's really the best
coffee website out there.
So get 50% off your first order
by clicking on the link
in the description,
or use the promo code Legal50 at checkout.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Class actions, coffee, whatever.
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this other
Legal Eagle video here.
I think you'll really like it.
So click on this video
or I'll see you in court.